hello rejects I'm Greg
I'm John we're gonna watch today's video
clueless gamer from Conan O'Brien Final
Fantasy XV with Elijah Wood but before
we do any of that 15 my darling
it's Roman numerals from ancient Greece
history jokes now with to get to the
shout out my favorite thing is when you
stare Amina we'd like to give a quick
shout out to today's sponsor amino apps
more specifically the final fantasy
amino just like the topic of today's
video which you can find in the App
Store's for both iPhone and Android if
you're a huge final fantasy fan and you
want to get online and talk and share
with other Final Fantasy fans from
around the world this is the app for you
whether it's Final Fantasy 15 or Final
Fantasy 3 there is a conversation to be
had on the Final Fantasy Amino it's
everything you love about a message
board we're an old-school chatroom
updated for the modern age right in the
palm of your hand the app has a built-in
newsfeed one-on-one chat forms and more
you can even chat with us we have a
profile find us real rejects all one
word lowercase you can join us and
others in public discussions with fellow
fans follow people make new friends
share your art and a whole lot more you
can also start polls post blogs enter
challenges one of my favorite threads I
found while I was just poking around was
the artwork sharing thread cuz that
makes me happy you know people drawing
you know their favorite characters and
stuff uploading it sharing them with
each other that's always fun right there
are tons of conversations that say
pardon and if something's missing
you could start a conversation of your
very own Final Fantasy 7 was a pretty
big deal when we were growing up
everybody had ps1 people were playing
like mad and since we talked about
remakes a lot on this channel we decided
to get on the board and start a
discussion about what people are excited
to see in the new Final Fantasy 7 remake
cuz that's coming out shortly and we've
already gotten a few hits back yes we
have so go deep geek out and download
the ultimate fan experience for Final
Fantasy Amino for free on iphone and
android start your conversation
John I think I'm feel like wearing my
spider-man shirt I feel like you should
get your spider-man shirt on and this
sweater is getting hot but maybe if I
put on a different sweater I'll be a
little less hot but maybe you still warm
still yes a cold ice mantle what you
know we're called the real rejects this
is all film related right now we're
about to watch the Final Fantasy Versus
in is a film it is a film linked six
degrees of separation would both makes
and is in films and camera brands on TV
that's all this like interviews a lot of
celebrities he does interview a lot we
have an excuse to watch this now today
I'm excited because we are getting a
special early look the newest agent here
in one of the longest-running video game
series of all time Final Fantasy 15 and
joining me today Elijah Wood thanks for
doing this he's got coach Ernie gaming i
am i've been forewarned that this game
is a little strange so this game takes
place on earth like planet called yose
and basically on this planet there is a
magical crystal I always a crystal and
we like that I'm sorry or a ring but
there's always
[Music]
or you must get the sound of hardness
you will be up Prince Noctis Lucius
calum your father with a nickname again
practice Lucius Taylor as a don't ask me
too many questions cuz they actually
tell me ya know like you have to be a
formal address whoa you know what this
is this is like middle-earth entourage
here comes agent remember good luck with
your Japanese nightclub wait oopsie car
broke down
right right Jurgen where's your car
[Music]
that's not a speaking I love it is this
really happening are we literally people
shooting a car through a desert why is
this a game I don't know but that's what
you're supposed to do yeah this is where
I struggle with our peachy's because
it's a lot of just walking around
talking to folks kind of buy a potion
don't have any money or any heartache
money I got no credit this is worth
scrap tanam that could play
there's nothing is going to happen we're
waiting for things that can't happen
be happy to pay your services if you're
up to the challenge
how bad sounds like a journey nothing
like running in the desert wearing
leather kind of like a bully back it's
the guys that are left for mistake this
is what they do now Justin will get back
with this why is he going
but he doesn't return our calls ah this
game should be called wait for your
death in real time further and further
away from my car be wise to rest up
before we set out good thing we have
that coin intent in our weather jet
skier it was the chips they got a bag of
chips those jackets have deep pockets
well we just decided to move forward
because that part of the game was
killing us I'm Erin Dennis this is
Dennis so at this point in the game the
wedding has been called off why I'm in
cold blood political reasons but you're
gonna walk over here and some ladies
you're gonna hear over here some ladies
and maybe I have a mission they're
extending the exhibit for lady when the
phrase wedding dress the dress we read
about in the papers Doug I think they
read about a dress yeah they're gonna
check out
papers this is a real sense looks to
think about the ceremony I've never been
this confused by first or the community
saying something are we meant to be
confuse no I mean it couldn't possibly
makes it well you know the thing is a
video game as written by James Joyce
it's just a matter so hated the guy fix
our car he did but instead of the car
one of the great things about Final
Fantasy that's in every game are these
things called chocobos oh did the
chicken I want to grab the chick so why
do we get the car fixed and spend so
much time getting the car fit we could
just wait and get on a chicken and move
around much more easily I don't know
superacid
what time correct fit I don't know no
idea what our mission is we're headed
towards the mysterious tremors in the
area we're gonna go investigate okay why
guys at our job well we're gonna get
we're gonna with me with the
seismologists okay oh there he is just
waiting for us it's Kevin Spacey and
Angela Merkel there's gonna be some kind
of beast right the earthquakes there's
gonna be it's gonna be like oh [ __ ] whoa
terrifying
oh it's a really impressive Beast could
have started the game with this thing
[Music]
you keep doing this for good facing the
corner tell me when something happens
was that it
that was the battle but it did something
happen that's it actually so now we just
did to suss him out and then when you
actually battling it takes three real
days what's the point
seriously reaching real days a 72
real-time hours - one time I beat on a
worm for 72 hours I was any relic longer
than I've played any game for clueless
game you've been playing for a really
long this is the longest we've ever
played a game and we don't even know I
don't know what we achieved I don't know
what we were trying to achieve and I
have no sense of satisfaction just leave
it on this way yeah leave it on this cuz
this is um something a guy and a girl
sitting on a bed in a motel chatting you
have nothing happening this whole thing
it's like an epic blue balls wasted
hahahaha that's your fame final thing
[Applause]
start it now the chameleons are outside
and I didn't realize they're watching
this and complain viciously oh there's
the beauty the only way out of that door
and they're still watching what's
happening now is more thrilling oh hello
you can order go in this game for seven
months so you helped build this right
what's up
[Music]
camera cut because of you
nothing's on the field that's that good
job
[Applause]
whoa Wow you know I've seen a lot of
clueless gamers I've never seen him that
bored before I love Conan so much as he
managed to make beam board pretty funny
oh yo it seems like he just sat but they
seemed like Elijah was trying to figure
it out and Conan just sat back and just
started doing stand-up whatever happened
to the game yeah he's incredible like
making fun of what's going on in the
yeah yeah yeah yeah like dropping
references and yeah back and for yeah
what and having Aaron blyer come into
you know frequently to be the sort of
geek foils you know it's like they have
a great three-man diamond like it
becomes a sketch even though it's not
really a sketch either
I mean Conan must have gotten the
permission to like just behave but I
kind of love this video for that because
this is err on TV he's not promoting the
game in a positive way like usually
freaking out or having an amazing time
and he doesn't he doesn't even seem like
he's trying to force himself to have a
good time you can't have a good time
with a game we still making it funny and
I think people have embraced that lately
because you know a lot of people are
starting to allow comedians to do these
kinds of ads in a more like silly way
and a little less like you have to make
it look amazing away yeah you know it's
like may I make a sketch out of it sure
just as long as you say its name a
million times but there are people who
are really into games like that well
yeah and that's that was the thing I was
realizing lost watching this videos like
even in games that I played lately there
has been an effort to add like more
realistic condition yeah I'm like more
especially timeframes yeah timeframes
are so like gnarly now you can't just
run or speed everywhere yeah more I do
think that's got a weed out a certain
amount of the population who you know
only plays to plug and play and have a
good time you know like this seems like
you got a Mersenne it kind of like metal
gear was where it's like you only commit
to this
oh you're they like be a lot easier to
commit to it looked
yeah well cos metal you you have the
whole like she could go down at any bow
yeah exactly we're still he's the the
prologue of this game seemed like
interesting or school yeah a good place
to place learning stuff these are always
sort of immersive RPGs that way so I
guess they've always had that in their
DNA yeah it seems like this is a gamer
eat
like yo you gotta really be invested
yeah cuz Conan he just like you know
he's only gonna play at the one time
yeah exactly so something that's more
media - yes if there's one celebrity I
wouldn't mind starting his own reaction
channel it's Elijah Wood he thinks that
I just I think Conan could do a terrific
let's play channel and Elijah Wood could
do a great reaction video cuz like he
just looks so like I just kept watching
his face cuz he just looks so kind of
like puzzled by but still into what's
going on
you know this guy's full of knowledge
Elijah Wood yeah he's a really
knowledgeable guy he seems like the kind
of guy who watches a lot of things and
reads a lot of yes yeah keep spirit AJ
he's very up - like I'm right he'll take
time to read books as well as watch a
[ __ ] ton of movies and shows i am always
feeling like i don't have time to do all
that in a day and i feel like a lot of
work and accomplish so much in like one
day it seems to have this natural i
think it's why you're saying he have a
great reaction job because it seems that
this natural fascination with things
yeah yeah
natural interesting curiosity you know
he seems really fascinated by life i
really learned to love him a lot more
when I saw him on movie fights that was
like oh the best episodes of it Ross
again yeah I agree
big reason why I mean he's got his own
production company he's got two new you
know and stuff like that so like he's
making cool weird movies and stuff and
yeah he's popping up Cummins Let's Plays
are like this is the artist let's plays
an agent there do they like you
extremely well on you - yeah I mean good
old-fashioned homegrown comedies
I love Conan I do too I love Elijah Wood
I want to be moaning and Conan I want to
be moaning I've got enough I can make
that joke I'm living and I feel like
you'd be good to receive Elijah's wood
stoner comedy if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to day become
a reject
Jon facebook.com slash bullet house
facebook.com slash the real rejects
reasons to jerry on instagram and
twitter go to amino apps go to limine
elapsed